ya hemos explorado la versión
bidimensional del teorema de la
divergencia donde si teníamos una región
digamos r digamos una región r de esta
forma y también deberíamos tener bueno
esta frontera que vamos a llamarse y
déjenme ponerla con color verde esta es
nuestra frontera de nuestra región y
también para usar el teorema de la
divergencia necesitamos un campo
vectorial definido sobre todo todo el
espacio ok entonces teníamos un campo
vectorial donde que fuera digamos
cubriendo de esta forma y como lo pinté
aquí más o menos podríamos decir que su
divergencia es positiva verdad el punto
es que aquí tenemos un campo vectorial y
lo que nos decía es que el flujo que es
no es otra cosa más que tomarnos el
campo vectorial y multiplicarlo hacer el
producto punto con el vector normal
unitario
o un vector normal exterior digamos que
puede ser este de aquí si este que es
ortogonal a la curva frontera este es al
que le llamamos vector normal
y después de eso tomamos el que
multiplicamos por una pequeña fracción
de deere ok y aquí sumamos todo esto si
lo sumamos todo esto a lo largo de
nuestra curva c entonces aquí estamos
definiendo el flujo del campo vectorial
a lo largo a través de la frontera va a
ser igual a la suma si sumamos todas
todas las todas dejen en lo escribo si
sumamos toda la divergencia que hay aquí
adentro y después lo multiplicamos por
un pedacito de área de esta región ok
digamos esta es la porción de área
entonces qué es lo que vamos a sumar
vamos a sumar toda la divergencia de
nuestro campo vectorial
sobre toda la región r eso es lo que nos
está dando el teorema de la divergencia
y que esencialmente pudimos obtener a
través del teorema de green obtuvimos
eso del teorema de green entonces por
ejemplo también podríamos déjenme
construir otro ejemplo si tuviéramos una
región aquí
una nueva región r y vamos a pintar otro
campo vectorial que digamos que fuera
constante en todas en todo punto sale
entonces tenemos un campo vectorial que
es constante en todos lados entonces
como pensaríamos el teorema de la
divergencia bueno veamos que de este
lado el flujo o la cantidad digamos como
ve de masa o de materia que está
saliendo a través de esta curva frontera
que le voy a llamar otra vez
ok entonces el flujo es positivo verdad
de este lado como que la materia si está
saliendo sin embargo de aquí hasta
digamos por aquí la materia está
entrando entonces el flujo es negativo
en este caso podríamos pensar como que
en realidad el flujo que hay a lo largo
de toda esta curva es cero y eso tiene
que ver porque la divergencia de este
campo vectorial pues también es cero no
por ejemplo también podríamos pensar que
si tenemos esta otra región r
ok no importa el chiste es que sean
regiones pues digamos bonitas para fines
de lo que queremos y pintamos un campo
vectorial que esté digamos más que más
que pensar en una divergencia de hay que
pensar como en una convergencia es decir
como que se está aproximando de esta
forma
más o menos no es que así se le llame
convergencia sino a lo mejor para fines
de este dibujo
sería conveniente llamarle así aquí en
realidad el flujo a través de ésta o a
través de esta frontera es es negativo
está entrando verdad y eso hará que si
sumamos en la divergencia sobre el del
campo vectorial a lo largo de toda esta
región pues en realidad la divergencia
va digamos que está apuntando hacia
adentro del campo vectorial entonces su
divergencia es negativa entonces todo
esto coincide y en realidad coincide
porque el campo vectorial con respecto
al al vector normal unitario pues tienen
direcciones opuestas digamos tienen
forman ángulos mayores a 90 grados o pi
medios en radiales ok entonces qué es lo
que vamos a tratar de hacer en los
próximos vídeos vamos a tratar de
extender este concepto del teorema de la
divergencia pero no a dos dimensiones
sino a tres entonces vamos a pensar
déjenme dibujarlo de esta forma vamos a
pensar en una región del espacio que
igual vamos a llamar r que sea una
región sólida simple y digo vamos vamos
a definir mejor esto en en otros vídeos
pero esencialmente es que esta región
como que no se doble en sí misma ajá
como que no se no se auto intersecte que
no tenga no tengas formas muy extrañas
digamos como que que fuera como esto
digamos más o menos podemos pensar que
esto es como de alguna forma elíptico a
jan más o menos espero se entienda que
éstas son como con una especie de
meridianos y de paralelos ok entonces
que sea más o menos de esta forma o al
menos que la la región la podemos
separar en en otras en otras regiones
ajenas digamos que no se auto
intersectan que no se doblan en sí
mismas que sean en esencia regiones
sólidas y simples ok y además de esta
ere vamos a tener que definir a la
frontera a una frontera s que se va a
ser la frontera la frontera de nuestra
región r
ok que es esencialmente la cáscara de
esta de esta región también vamos a
necesitar una un vector normal exterior
bueno vamos a orientar la la región o la
superficie de esta región de tal forma
que nuestro vector normal sea exterior
qué quiere decir eso pues que justamente
apunta hacia afuera
hacia fuera de la superficie ok entonces
qué es lo que vamos a hacer para usar el
o para deducir un teorema de la
divergencia bueno esta idea que tenemos
aquí detrás en dos dimensiones la vamos
a llevar a tres entonces aquí si nos
damos cuenta esta es la integral sobre
una frontera entonces vamos a hacer la
integral sobre la frontera donde la
frontera es s vamos a sumar el campo
vectorial o el flujo a lo largo de esta
frontera es decir tenemos el campo
vectorial vamos a definir un campo
vectorial no se puede ser de muchas
formas raras esto está definido incluso
desde adentro
aquí como estoy pintando otra vez pues
estoy como pensando en un en que su
divergencia es positiva es decir esta se
está saliendo de aquí adentro estamos
entonces este campo vectorial vamos a
hacer el producto punto con nuestro
vector normal exterior para más o menos
ir midiendo en el que tanto que tanto
varia varianza o que tanto se
diferencian
direcciones y después vamos a
multiplicar por una pequeña porción de
área digamos que tenemos aquí sobre la
cáscara
porción de área de baja y todo esto lo
vamos a sumar a lo largo de nuestra
frontera que es la superficie ese y esto
siguiendo esta idea anterior debería ser
la la suma de la divergencia pero en
toda la región completa es decir vamos a
tener la suma sobre toda la sobre toda
la región r que esto ya es un cuerpo
sólido entonces es una integral triple
de la divergencia de la divergencia del
campo vectorial por una pequeña porción
de volumen de volumen de este verde
sólido entonces vamos a pensar en este
volumen sale entonces aquí vamos a sumar
la divergencia y coincide más o menos la
idea que teníamos en dos dimensiones con
esta es decir por ejemplo aquí el campo
vectorial pues más o menos apunta en
dirección del vector normal exterior eso
quiere decir eso querría decir que
esta parte sería positiva de otra forma
también la divergencia en este caso pues
es positiva
en efecto cumple con esa idea de hacer
una divergencia de salir como que
pretende salir del campo vectorial
entonces esta parte de aquí esta parte
de aquí es el flujo es el flujo a través
a través de la frontera o de la
superficie de la superficie muy bien
también tenemos ese concepto acá arriba
en él
en el caso de en dos dimensiones porque
esto de acá esto de aquí es el flujo es
el flujo pero a través a través de la
curva de la curva en ambos casos es la
frontera y aquí del lado derecho pues
estamos sumando la divergencia del campo
vectorial en toda la región interior ok
entonces espero esto les les dé mucha
intuición de lo que el teorema de la
divergencia nos dice esto espero que sea
claro y que al menos haya extendido
nuestro sentido común en los próximos
vídeos haremos
haremos ejemplos para manipular estas
integrales de aquí abajo y en otro par
de vídeos vamos a tratar de demostrar el
teorema de la divergencia